bolivia apuesta por las energías
renovables a 3700 metros sobre el nivel
del mar esta planta solar situada en el
departamento de oruro es considerada la
más alta del mundo con 300.000 paneles
fotovoltaicos para captar la energía
solar el proyecto que inició en 2019
bajo el mandato de evo morales busca la
transformación energética del país como
país hemos trazado una línea para lograr
una robustez de nuestra matriz eléctrica
y creemos que hasta el momento se ha
venido efectuando y lógicamente en
nuestro país tiene una potencialidad
enorme en cuanto a fuentes de energías
renovables la quema del gas sigue siendo
un elemento básico en la vida cotidiana
de los bolivianos
especialmente ya que es un sector
subsidiado
la verdadera reconversión
de la matriz energética
pasa por eliminar subsidios en la medida
que el gas natural en nuestro país esté
subsidiado no hay la posibilidad para
que energías renovables puedan competir
con el precio del gas subsidiado a pesar
de la implementación de energías
renovables el gobierno ha invertido
264 millones de dólares en la
explotación de combustibles fósiles en
los últimos meses el país reportó un
aumento del 131 por ciento en las ventas
de gas licuado de petróleo a otros
países